[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not the man you want you've made a
mistake
i'm in touch with technological advances
pretty well everywhere and i can tell
you that no one has produced anything
like this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
armed
do
[Music]
[Music]
i'm
um
armed
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm not the man you want you've made a
i'm in touch with mistake
advisors pretty well everywhere and i
can tell you that no one has produced
anything like this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
armed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
armed
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
hello everyone uh sorry for the delay um
thanks for coming
and um sorry i had some technical
difficulties
really neat ai for this
so uh what we want to
show today is that tesla is
much more than an electric car company
that we have
deep ai activity
in
hardware on the inference level on the
training level
and
basically we
i think we're
i think arguably the leaders in real
world ai as it applies to the real world
um
and those of you who have seen the full
self-driving
beta i can appreciate the rate at which
the tesla
neural net is learning to to drive
and um
so this is a particular application of
ai but i think there's there's more
there are more applications uh down the
road that will make sense and we'll talk
about that later in the presentation
but um
yeah we basically want to encourage
anyone who is interested in
solving real-world ai problems
at either the hardware or the software
level to join tesla or consider drawing
tesla
so let's see we'll start off with andre
great
okay hi everyone um welcome
my name is andre and um i am
i lead the vision team here at tesla
autopilot and i'm incredibly excited to
be here uh to kick off this section
giving you a technical deep dive into
the autopilot stack and showing you all
the under the hood components that go
into making the car drive all by itself
so we're going to start off with the
vision component here
now in division component what we're
trying to do is we're trying to design a
neural network that processes the raw
information
which in our case is the eight cameras
that are positioned around the vehicle
and they send us images and we need to
process that in real time into what we
call the vector space and this is a
three-dimensional representation of
everything you need for driving so this
is the three-dimensional positions of
lines edges curbs
traffic signs traffic lights
cars their positions orientations
depth velocities and so on
so here i'm showing a video of
actually hold on
apologies
so here i'm showing the video of the raw
inputs that come into the stack and then
neural processes that into the vector
space and you are seeing parts of that
vector space rendered in the instrument
cluster on the car
now
what i find kind of fascinating about
this is that we are effectively building
a synthetic animal from the ground up so
the car can be thought of as an animal
it moves around it senses the
environment and uh you know acts
autonomously and intelligently and
we are building all the components from
scratch in-house so we are building of
course all of the mechanical components
of the body the nervous system which is
all the electrical components and for
our purposes the brain of the autopilot
and specifically for this section the
synthetic visual cortex
now the biological visual cortex
actually has quite intricate structure
and a number of areas
that organize the information flow of
this brain and so in particular in our
in your visual cortices
the information hits the
light hits the retina it goes through
the lgn all the way to the back of your
visual cortex goes through areas v1 v2
v4 the it the venture on the dorsal
streams and the information is organized
in a certain layout and so when we are
designing the visual cortex of the car
we also want to design the neural
network architecture of how the
information flows in the system
so the processing starts in the
beginning when light hits our artificial
retina and we are going to process this
information with neural networks now i'm
going to roughly organize this section
chronologically so starting off with
some of the neural networks and what
they looked like roughly four years ago
when i joined the team and how they have
developed over time
so
roughly um
four years ago the car was mostly
driving in a single lane going forward
on the highway and so it had to keep
lane and it had to keep distance away
from the car in front of us and at that
time all of processing was only on
individual image level so a single image
has to be analyzed by a neural net and
make little pieces of the vector space
process that into little pieces of the
vector space so this processing
took the following shape we take a 1280
by 960 input and this is 12 bit integers
streaming in at roughly 36 hertz now
we're going to process that with the
neural network so instantiate a feature
extractor backbone in this case we use
residual neural networks so we have a
stem and a number of residual blocks
connected in series
now the specific class of resnets that
we use are regnets because we like this
is like a very rec nets offer a very
nice design space for neural networks
because they allow you to very nicely
trade off latency and uh accuracy
now these reg nets give us as an output
a number of features at different
resolutions in different scales so in
particular on the very bottom of this
feature hierarchy we have very high
resolution information with very low
channel counts and all the way at the
top we have low spatial low resolution
especially but high channel counts so on
the bottom we have a lot of neurons that
are really scrutinizing the detail of
the image and on the top we have neurons
that can see most of the image and a lot
of that context have a lot of that scene
context
we then like to process this with
feature pyramid networks in our case we
like to use by fbns and they get the
mult they get to multiple scales to talk
to each other effectively and share a
lot of information so for example if
you're a neuron all the way down in the
network and you're looking at a small
patch and you're not sure this is a car
or not it definitely helps to know from
the top players that hey you are
actually in the vanishing point of this
highway and so that helps you
disambiguate that this is probably a car
after a buy fbn and a feature fusion
across scales we then go into task
specific heads so for example if you are
doing object detection we have a one
stage yolo like object detector here
where we initialize a raster and there's
a binary bit per position telling you
whether or not there's a car there and
then in addition to that if there is
here's a bunch of other attributes you
might be interested in so the x y with
height offset or any of the other
attributes like what type of a car is
this and so on
so this is for the detection by itself
now very quickly we discovered that we
don't just want to detect cars we want
to do a large number of tasks so for
example we want to do traffic light
recognition and detection a lane
prediction and so on so very quickly we
conversion this kind of architectural
layout where there's a common shared
backbone and then branches off into a
number of heads so
we call these uh therefore hydronets and
these are the heads of the hydra
now
this architectural layout has a number
of benefits so number one
because of the feature sharing we can
amortize the forward pass inference in
the car at test time and so this is very
efficient to run
because if we had to have a backbone for
every single task that would be a lot of
backbones in the car
number two this decouples all of the
tasks so we can individually work on
every one task in isolation and for
example we can we can upgrade any of the
data sets or change some of the
architecture of the head and so on and
you are not impacting any of the other
tasks and so we don't have to revalidate
all the other tasks which can be
expensive
and number three because there's this
bottleneck here and features
what we do fairly often is that we
actually cache these features to disk
and when we are doing these fine tuning
uh workflows we only fine-tune from from
the cached features up and only find you
in the heads so most often in terms of
our training workflows we will do an
end-to-end training run once in a while
where we train everything jointly then
we cache the features
at the multiscale feature level and then
we fine-tune off of that for a while and
then end-to-end train once again and so
on
so here's the kinds of predictions that
we were obtaining i would say several
years ago now
uh from one of these hydronitis so again
we are processing individual images
there we go we are processing just
individual image and we're making a
large number of predictions about these
images so for example here you can see
predictions of the stop signs uh the
stop lines uh the lines the edges the
cars uh the traffic lights uh the curbs
here
uh whether or not the car is sparked uh
all of the static objects like trash
cans cones and so on and everything here
is coming out of the net
here in this case out of the hydra net
so that was all fine and great but as we
worked towards fsd we quickly found that
this is not enough so where this first
started to break was when we started to
work on smart summon here i am showing
some of the predictions of only the curb
detection task and i'm showing it now
for every one of the cameras
so we'd like to wind our way around the
parking lot to find the person who is
summoning the car now the problem is
that you can't just directly drive on
image space predictions you actually
need to cast them out and form some kind
of a vector space around you
so we attempted to do this using c plus
and developed what we call
the occupancy tracker at the time
so here we see that the curb detections
from the images are being stitched up
across camera scenes camera boundaries
and over time
now there are two pro two major problems
i would say with the setup number one we
very quickly discovered that tuning the
occupancy tracker and all of its hyper
parameters was extremely complicated you
don't want to do this explicitly by hand
in c plus you want this to be inside the
neural network and train that end to end
number two we very quickly discovered
that the image space is not the correct
output space uh you don't want to make
predictions in image space you really
want to make it directly in the vector
space so here's a way of illustrating
the issue
so here i'm showing on the first row the
predictions of our curves and our lines
in red and blue and
they look great in the image but once
you cast them out into the vector space
things start to look really terrible and
we are not going to be able to drive on
this so
you see how the predictions are quite
bad in vector space and the reason for
this fundamentally is because you need
to have an extremely accurate depth per
pixel in order to actually do this
projection and so you can imagine just
how high of the bar it is to predict
that depth so accurately in these tiny
in every single pixel of the image and
also if there's any occluded area where
you'd like to make predictions you will
not be able to because it's not an image
space
concept in that case
so we very quickly
real of
the other problems with this by the way
is also for object detection if you are
only making predictions per camera then
sometimes you will encounter cases like
this where a single car actually spans
five of the eight cameras
and so if you are making individual
predictions then no single camera since
sees all of the car and so obviously
you're not going to be able to do a very
good job of predicting that whole car
and it's going to be incredibly
difficult to fuse these measurements
so we have this intuition that what we'd
like to do instead is we'd like to take
all of the images and simultaneously
feed them into a single neural net and
directly output in vector space now this
is very easily said much more difficult
to actually achieve but roughly we want
to lay out a neural net in this way
where we process every single image with
a backbone
and then we want to somehow fuse them
and we want to re-represent it the the
features from image space features to
directly some kind of vector space
features and then go into the decoding
of the head
now
um so there are two problems with this
problem number one
how do you actually create the neural
network components that do this
transformation
and you have to make it differentiable
so that end-to-end training is possible
and number two uh
the if you want vector space predictions
from your neural net you need vector
specif based data sets so just labeling
images and so on is not going to get you
there you need vector space labels we're
going to talk a lot more about problem
number two later in the talk for now i
want to focus on the neural network
architectures so i'm going to deep dive
into problem number one
so here's the rough problem right we're
trying to have this bird's eye view
prediction instead of image space
predictions so for example let's focus
on a single pixel in the output space in
yellow and this pixel is trying to
decide am i part of a curb or not as an
example
and now where should the support for
this kind of a prediction come from in
the image space
well we know roughly how the cameras are
positioned and their extrinsics and
intrinsics so we can roughly project
this point into the camera images and
you know the evidence for whether or not
this is a curve may come from somewhere
here in the images the problem is that
this projection is really hard to
actually get correct because it is a
function of the road surface the road
surface could be sloping up or sloping
down or also there could be other data
dependent issues for example there could
be occlusion due to a car so if there's
a car occluding this this viewport this
this part of the image then actually you
may want to pay attention to a different
part of the image not the part where it
projects and so because this is data
dependent it's really hard to have a
fixed transformation for this component
so in order to solve this issue
we use a transformer to represent this
space and this transformer
uses multi-headed self-attention and
blocks off it
in this case actually we can get away
with even a single block
doing a lot of this work
and
effectively what this does is you
initialize a raster of the size of the
output space that you would like and you
tile it with positional encodings with
size and coses in the output space and
then these get encoded with an mlp into
a set of query vectors
and then all of the images and their
features also emit their own keys and
values and then the queries keys and
values feed into the multi-headed
self-attention and so effectively what's
happening is that every single image
piece is broadcasting in its key
what it is what is it a part of so hey
i'm part of a pillar in roughly this
location and i'm seeing this kind of
stuff and that's in the key and then
every query is something along the lines
of hey i'm a pixel in the output space
at this position and i'm looking for
features of this type
then the keys and the queries interact
multiplicatively and then the values get
pulled accordingly
and so this re-represents the space and
we find this to be very effective for
this transformation so if you do all of
the engineering correctly this again is
very easily said
difficult to do you do all of the
engineering correctly um
there's one more there's no problem
actually before
i'm not sure what's up with the slides
so one more thing you have to be careful
with some of the details here when you
are trying to get this to work so in
particular all of our cars
uh are slightly cockeyed in a slightly
different way and so if you're doing
this transformation from image space to
the output space you really need to know
what your camera calibration is and you
need to feed that in somehow into the
neural net and so you could definitely
just like concatenate the camera
calibrations of all of the images and
somehow feed them in with an mlp
but actually we found that we can do
much better by transforming all of the
images into a synthetic virtual camera
using a special rectification transform
so this is what that would look like
we insert a new layer right above the
image rectification layer it's a
function of camera calibration and it
translates all of the images into a
virtual common camera so if you were to
average up a lot of repeater images for
example which faced at the back
you would without doing this you would
get a kind of a blur but after doing the
rectification transformation you see
that the back mirror gets really crisp
so once you do this uh this improves the
performance quite a bit
so here are some of the results so on
the left we are seeing what we had
before and on the right we're now seeing
significantly improved predictions
coming directly out of the neural net
this is a multi-camera network
predicting directly in vector space and
you can see that it's basically night
and day uh
you can actually drive on this and uh
this took some time and some engineering
and incredible work from the ai team to
actually get this to work and deploy and
make it efficient in the car
this also improved a lot of our object
detection so for example here in this
video i'm showing single camera
predictions in orange and multi-camera
predictions in blue and basically if you
if you can't predict these cars if you
are only seeing a tiny sliver of a car
so your detections are not going to be
very good and their positions are not
going to be good but a multi-camera
network does not have an issue
here's another video from a more nominal
sort of situation and we see that as
these cars in this tight space cross
camera boundaries there's a lot of jank
that enters into the predictions and
basically the whole setup just doesn't
make sense especially for very large
vehicles like this one and we can see
that the multi-camera networks struggle
significantly less with these kinds of
predictions
okay so at this point we have
multi-camera networks and they're giving
predictions directly in vector space but
we are still operating at every single
instant in time completely independently
so very quickly we discovered that
there's a large number of predictions we
want to make that actually require the
video context and we need to somehow
figure out how to feed this into the net
so in particular is this car parked or
not is it moving how fast is it moving
is it still there even though it's
temporarily occluded or for example if
i'm trying to predict the road geometry
ahead
it's very helpful to know of the signs
or the road markings that i saw 50
meters ago
so
we try to develop
we try to insert video modules into our
neural network architecture and this is
kind of one of the solutions that we've
converged on
so we have the multi-scale features as
we had them from before and what we are
going to now insert is a feature queue
module that is going to cache some of
these features over time
and then a video module that is going to
fuse this information temporally and
then we're going to continue into the
heads that do the decoding
now i'm going to go into both of these
blocks one by one also in addition
notice here that we are also feeding in
the kinematics this is basically the
velocity and the acceleration that's
telling us about how the car is moving
so not only are not only are we going to
keep track of what we're seeing from all
the cameras but also how the car has
traveled
so here's the feature queue and the
rough layout of it we are basically
concatenating these features um
over time and the kinematics of how the
car has moved
and the positional encodings and that's
being concatenated encoded and stored in
a feature queue
and that's going to be consumed by a
video module now there's a few details
here again to get right so in particular
with respect to the pop and push
mechanisms and when do you push and how
and
especially when do you push basically so
here's a cartoon diagram illustrating
some of the challenges here
there's going to be the ego cars coming
from the bottom and coming up to this
intersection here and then traffic is
going to start crossing in front of us
and it's going to temporarily start
occluding some of the cars ahead and
then we're going to be stuck at this
intersection for a while and just
waiting our turn this is something that
happens all the time and is a cartoon
representation of some of the challenges
here
so number one with respect to
the feature queue and when we want to
push into a queue obviously we'd like to
have some kind of a time-based queue
where for example we enter the features
into the queue say every 27 milliseconds
and so if a car gets temporarily
occluded then the neural network now has
the power to be able to look and
reference the memory in time and and
learn the association that hey even
though this thing looks occluded right
now there's a record of it in my
previous features and i can use this to
still make a detection
so that's kind of like the more obvious
one but the one that we also discovered
is necessary in our case is for example
suppose you're trying to make
predictions about the road surface and
the road geometry ahead and you're
trying to predict that i'm in a turning
lane and the lane next to us is going
straight
then
it's really necessary to know about the
line markings and the signs and
sometimes they occur a long time ago and
so if you only have a time-based queue
you may forget the features while you're
waiting at your red light so in addition
to a time-based q we also have a
space-based view so we push every time
the car travels a certain fixed distance
so some of these details actually can
matter quite a bit and so in this case
we have a time based key and a space
base key to cache our features and that
continues into the video module
now for the video module we looked at a
number of possibilities of how to fuse
this information temporally so we looked
at three-dimensional convolutions
transformers axial transformers in an
effort to try to make them more
efficient recurrent neural networks over
a large number of flavors
but the one that we actually like quite
a bit as well and i want to spend some
time on is a spatial recurrent neural
network video module and so what we're
doing here is
because of the structure of the problem
we're driving on two-dimensional
surfaces we can actually organize the
hidden state into a two-dimensional
lattice and then as the car is driving
around we update only the parts that are
near the car and where the car has
visibility so as the car is driving
around we are using the kinematics to
integrate the position of the car in the
hidden features
grid and we are only updating the rnn at
the points where where we have uh that
are nearby us sort of
so here's an example of what that looks
like
here what i'm going to show you is the
car driving around
and
we're looking at the hidden state of
this rnn
and these are different channels in the
hidden state so you can see that this is
after optimization and training this
neural net you can see that some of the
channels are keeping track of different
aspects of the road like for example the
centers of the road the edges the lines
the road surface and so on
here's another cool video of this so
this is looking at the mean of the first
10 channels in the hidden state for
different
traversals of different intersections
and all i want you to see basically is
that there's cool activity as the
recurrent neural network is keeping
track of what's happening at any point
in time and you can imagine that we've
now given the power to the neural
network to actually selectively read and
write to this memory so for example if
there's a car right next to us and is
occluding some parts of the road then
now the network has a has the ability to
not write to those locations but when
the car goes away and we have a really
good view then the recurring neural net
can say okay we have very clear
visibility we definitely want to write
information about what's in that part of
space
here's a few predictions that show
what this looks like
so here we are making predictions about
the road boundaries in red intersection
areas in blue
road centers and so on so we're only
showing a few of the predictions here
just to keep the visualization clean
um
and yeah this is this is done by the
spatial rnn and this is only showing a
single clip a single traversal but you
can imagine there could be multiple
trips through here and basically number
of cars a number of clips could be
collaborating to build this map
basically and effectively an hd map
except it's not in a space of explicit
items it's in a space of features of a
recurrent neural network which is kind
of cool i haven't seen that before
the video networks also improved our
object detection quite a bit so in this
example i want to show you a case where
there are two cars
over there and one car is going to drive
by and occlude them briefly so look at
what's happening with the single frame
and the video predictions as the cars
pass in front of us
yeah so that makes a lot of sense so a
quick
playthrough through what's happening
when both of them are in view the
predictions are roughly equivalent
and you are seeing multiple orange boxes
because they're coming from different
cameras
when they are occluded the single frame
networks drop the detection but the
video module remembers it and we can
persist the cars and then when they are
only partially occluded the single frame
network is forced to make its best guess
about what it's seeing and it's forced
to make a prediction and it makes a
really terrible prediction but the video
module knows that there's only a partial
that you know it has the information and
knows that this is not a very easily
visible
part right now and doesn't actually take
that into account
we also saw significant improvements in
our ability to estimate depth and of
course especially velocity so here i'm
showing a clip from our remove the radar
push where we are seeing the radar depth
and velocity in green and we were trying
to
match or even surpass of course the
signal just from video networks alone
and what you're seeing here is in
orange we are seeing a single frame
performance
and in blue we are seeing again video
modules and so you see that the quality
of depth is much higher and for velocity
the orange signal of course you can't
get velocity out of a single frame
network so we use uh we just
differentiate depth to get that but the
video module actually is basically right
on top of the radar signal and so we
found that this worked extremely well
for us
so here's putting everything together
this is what our architectural roughly
looks like today so
we have raw images feeding on the bottom
they go through rectification layer to
correct for camera calibration and put
everything into a common uh virtual
camera we pass them through
regnets residual networks to process
them into a number of features at
different scales we fuse the multi-scale
information with by fbn this goes
through transformer module to
re-represent it into the vector space in
the output space this feeds into a
feature queue in time or space that gets
processed by a video module like the
spatial rnn and then continues into the
branching structure of the hydra net
with trunks and heads for all the
different tasks
and so that's the architecture roughly
what it looks like today and on the
right you are seeing some of its
predictions uh sort of visualize both in
a top-down vector space and also in
images so definitely uh
this architecture has definitely
complexified from just a very simple
image based single network about three
or four years ago and continues to
evolve um it's definitely quite
impressive now there's still
opportunities for improvements that the
team is actively working on for example
you'll notice that our fusion of time
and space is fairly late in neural
network terms so maybe we can actually
do earlier fusion of space or time and
do for example cost volumes or optical
flow-like networks on the bottom
or for example our outputs are dense
rasters and it's actually pretty
expensive to post-process some of these
dense rasters in the car and of course
we are under very strict latency
requirements so this is not ideal we
actually are looking into all kinds of
ways of predicting just the sparse
structure of the road maybe like you
know point by point or in some other
fashion that is
that doesn't require expensive
post-processing
but this basically is how you achieve a
very nice vector space and now i believe
ashok is going to talk about how we can
run playing control on top of it
[Applause]
thank you andre hi everyone my name is
ashok i lead the planning and controls
auto labeling and simulation teams
so like on dimension the visual networks
take dense video data and then compress
it down into a 3d vector space the role
of the planner now is to consume this
vector space and get the car to the
destination while maximizing the safety
comfort and the efficiency of the car
even back in 2019 our planet was pretty
capable driver it was able to stay in
the lanes make lane changes as necessary
and take exits off the highway but cdc
driving is much more complicated
radley there are
structured lane lines um vehicles do
much more free from driving then the car
has to respond to all of
curtains and crossing vehicles and
pedestrians doing funny things
what is the key problem in planning
number one the action space is very
non-convex
and number two it is high dimensional
what i mean by non-convex
is there can be multiple possible
solutions that can be independently good
but getting a globally consistent
solution is pretty tricky so there can
be pockets of local minima that the
planning can get stuck into
and secondly uh the high dimensionality
comes because the car needs to plan for
the next 10 to 15 seconds and needs to
produce the position velocities and
acceleration uh or this entire window
this is a lot of parameters to produce
at runtime
discrete search methods are really great
at solving non-context problems because
they are discrete they can they don't
get stuck in local minima whereas
continuous function optimization can
easily get stuck in local minima and
produce poor solutions that are not
great
on the other end for high dimensional
problems discrete search sucks because
of the
it is discrete it does not use any
graded information so literally has to
go and explore each point to know how
good it is whereas continuous
optimization use gradient-based methods
to very quickly go to a good solution
our solution to this printer problem is
to break it down hierarchically first
use a code search method to crunch down
the uh
non-convexity and come up with a convex
corridor and then use continuous
optimization techniques to make the
final smooth trajectory
let's see an example of how the search
operates
so here we're trying to do a lane change
in this case the car needs to do two
back to back lane changes to make the
left turn up ahead
for this the car searches over uh
different maneuvers um
so the the first one it searches is a
lane change that's close by but the
car breaks pretty harshly so it's pretty
uncomfortable
the next maneuver it tries does the lane
change bit late so it speeds up goes
beyond the other car goes in front of
the other cars and find it at the lane
change but now it risks missing the left
turn
we do thousands of such searches in a
very short time span
because these are all physics-based
models these features are very easy to
simulate and in the end we have a set of
candidates and we finally choose one
based on the optimality conditions of
safety comfort and easily making the
turn
so now the car has chosen this path and
you can see that as the car executes
this trajectory it pretty much matches
what we had planned the cyan plot on the
right side here and that one is the
actual velocity of the car and the white
line be underneath it is was the plan so
we are able to plan for 10 seconds here
and able to match that
when you see in hindsight so this is a
well-made plan
when driving alongside other agents it's
important to not just plan for ourselves
but instead we have to plan for everyone
jointly and optimize for the overall
scenes traffic flow
in order to do this what we do is we
literally run the autopilot planner on
every single relevant object in the
scene
here's an example of why that's
necessary
this is an auto corridor i'll let you
watch the video for a second
yeah that was autopilot driving an auto
corridor going around parked cars cones
and poles uh here there's a 3d view of
the same thing
the oncoming car arrives now and
autopilot slows down a little bit but
then realizes that we cannot yield to
them because we don't have any space to
our side but the other car can heal to
us instead so instead of just blindly
breaking here all of our reasons about
that car uh
has low enough velocity that they can
pull over and should yield to us because
we cannot yield to them and assertively
makes progress
a second oncoming car arrives now
this vehicle has higher velocity
and like i said earlier we literally run
the autopilot planner for the other
object so in this case we run the
printer for them that object's plan now
goes around their part their site's
parked cars and then after they pass the
parkours goes back to the right side of
the road for them
since we don't know what's in the mind
of the driver we actually have multiple
possible features for this car here one
feature is shown in red the other one is
shown as green
the green one is a plan that yields to
us but since this object's velocity and
acceleration are pretty high we don't
think that this person is going to yield
to us and they are actually going to go
around these sparked cars
so autopilot decides that okay i have
space here uh this person is definitely
going to come so i'm going to pull over
so as autopilot is pulling over we
notice that that car has chosen to yield
to us based on their yaw rate and their
acceleration and autopilot immediately
changes his mind and continues to make
progress
this is why we need to plan for everyone
because otherwise we wouldn't know that
this person is going to go around the
other park cars
and come back to their site if you
didn't do this autopilot would be too
timid and it would not be a practical
self-driving car
so now we saw how the search and
planning for other people set up
convicts valley uh finally we do a
continuous optimization to produce the
final trajectory that the planet uh
needs to take
here the grave uh thing is the convex
corridor and we initialize the spline in
heading and acceleration parameterized
over the arc length of the plan
and you can see that the
countermeasuration continuously makes
fine-grained changes to reduce all of
its cost some of the costs for example
are distance from obstacles
traversal time and comfort for comfort
you can see that the lateral
acceleration plots on the right have
nice trapezoidal shapes uh it's going to
come up yeah here on the right side the
green plot um that's a nice trapezoidal
shape and if you record on a human
trajectory this is pretty much how it
looked like the lateral jerk is also
minimized
so in summary we do a search for both us
and everyone else in the scene uh we set
up a context corridor and then optimize
for a smooth path
together these can do some really neat
things like
shown above
but driving looks a bit different in
other places like where i grew up from
um
it's very much more unstructured
cars and pedestrians cutting each other
arch braking honking um
it's a crazy world um
we can try to scale up these methods uh
but it's going to be really difficult to
efficiently solve this at runtime what
we instead want to do is use learning
based methods to efficiently solve them
um and i want to show why this is true
um so we're going to go from this
complicated problem to a much simpler
toy parking problem but still
illustrates the core of the issue
here this is a parking lot the ego car
is in blue and needs to park in the
green parking spot here so it needs to
go around the curbs the park cars and
the cones shown in orange here
let's do this simple bass line it's a
star the standard algorithm that uses a
ladder space search um and and the
heuristic here is a distance uh the
euclidean distance to the goal
so you can see that it directly shoots
towards the goal but very quickly gets
trapped in a local minima and it
backtracks from there
and then searches a different path to
try to go around this parkour
eventually it makes progress and gets to
the goal but ends up using 400 000 nodes
for making this
obviously this is a terrible heuristic
we want to do better than this so
if you added a navigation route to it
and has the car to follow the navigation
route while being close to the goal this
is what happens
the navigation route helps immediately
uh but still when it enter encounters uh
cones or other obstacles it basically
that's the same thing as before
backtracks and then searches that whole
new path and the support search has no
idea that these obstacles exist it
literally has to go there check if it's
in collision and if it's in collision
back up
the navigation heuristic helped but
still this took 22 000 notes
we can design more and more of these
heuristics to help the search make go
faster and faster but it's really
tedious and hard to design a globally
optimal heuristic
even if you had a distance function from
the cones that guided the search this
would not this would not be this would
only be effective for the single cone
but what we need is a global global
value function so instead of what we
want to use is neural networks to give
this heuristic for us
the visual networks produces vector
space and we have cars moving around in
it this basically looks like a atari
game
and it's a multiplayer version uh so we
can use techniques such as mu0 alpha
zero et cetera that was used to solve go
and other authority games to solve the
same problem so we're working on neural
networks that can produce state and
action distributions that can then be
plugged into multicolored research with
various cost functions
some of the cost functions can be
explicit cost functions like distance
like collisions comfort traversal time
etc but they can also be
interventions from the actual manual
driving events
we train such a network for this simple
parking problem so here again same
problem let's see how mcts researched us
so here you notice that the
planet is basically able to in one shot
make progress towards the goal uh to
notice that this is not even using a
navigation heuristic just given the
scene
the planet is able to go directly
towards the goal all the other options
you're seeing are possible options it's
not choosing any of them just using the
option that directly takes it towards
the goal
the reason is that the neural network is
able to absorb the global context of the
scene and then produce a value function
that effectively guides it towards the
global minima as opposed to getting
certain any local minima
so this only takes 288 notes and several
orders of magnitude less than what was
done in the a star with the equilibrium
distance heuristic
so this is what a final architecture is
going to look like the vision system is
going to crush down the dense video data
into a vector space
uh it's going to be consumed by both an
explicit planner and a neural network
planner in addition to this the network
panel can also consume intermediate
features of the network
together this produces a trajectory
distribution
and it can be optimized end to end both
with explicit cost functions and human
intervention and other imitation data
this then goes into explicit planning
function that
does whatever is easy for that and
produces the final steering and
acceleration commands for the car
with that we need to now explain how we
train these networks and for training
these networks we need uh large data
sets
um and wait i'm ready to speak briefly
about manual labeling
yeah so the data the story of data sets
is critical of course so far we've
talked only about neural networks but
neural networks only establish an upper
bound on your performance many of these
neural networks uh they have hundreds of
millions of parameters and these
hundreds of millions of parameters they
have to be set correctly
if you have a bad setting of parameters
it's not going to work so neural
networks are just an upper bound you
also need massive data sets to actually
train the correct algorithms inside them
now in particular i mentioned we want
data sets directly in the vector space
and so the really the question becomes
how can you accumulate because our
networks have hundreds of millions of
parameters how do you accumulate
millions and millions of vector space
examples that are clean and diverse
to actually train these neural networks
effectively
now so there's a story of data sets and
how they've evolved on the side of uh
all of the models and developments that
we've achieved
now in particular when i joined roughly
four years ago we were working with a
third party to obtain a lot of our data
sets now unfortunately we found very
quickly that working with a third party
to get data sets for something this
critical was just not going to cut it
the latency of working with a third
party was extremely high and honestly
the quality was not amazing and so in
the spirit of full vertical integration
at tesla we brought all of the labeling
in-house and so over time we've grown
more than one thousand person uh data
labeling org that is full of
professional labelers who are working
very closely with the engineers so
actually they're here in the u.s and
co-located with the engineers here in
the area as well and so we work very
closely with them and we also build um
all of the infrastructure for them from
scratch ourselves so we have a team we
are going to meet later today
that develops and maintains all of this
infrastructure for data labeling and so
here for example i'm showing some of the
screenshots of some of the latency
throughput and quality statistics that
we maintain about all of the labeling
workflows and the individual people
involved and all the tasks and how the
numbers of labels are growing over time
so we found this to be quite critical
and we're very proud of this
now in the beginning roughly three or
four years ago most of our labeling was
in image space and so you can
imagine that this is taking quite some
time to annotate an image like this and
this is what it looked like
where we are sort of drawing polygons
and polylines on top of
on top of these single individual images
as i mentioned we need millions of
vector space
labels so this is not going to cut it so
very quickly we graduated to
three-dimensional or four-dimensional
labeling where we are directly labeling
in vector space not in individual images
so here what i'm showing
is a clip and you are seeing a very
small reconstruction you're about to see
a lot more reconstructions soon but it's
very small reconstruction of the ground
plane on which the car drove and a
little bit of the point cloud here that
was reconstructed and what you're seeing
here is that the labeler is uh changing
the
labels directly in vector space and then
we are reprojecting those changes into
camera images uh so we're labeling
directly in vector space and this gave
us a massive increase in throughput for
a lot of our labels because you're
labeled once in 3d and then you get to
reproject
but even this we realized was actually
not going to cut it
so
because people and computers have
different pros and cons so people are
extremely good at things like semantics
but computers are very good at geometry
reconstruction triangulation tracking
and so really for us it's much more
becoming a story of how do humans and
computers collaborate to actually create
these vector space data sets and so
we're gonna not talk about auto labeling
which is some of the infrastructure
we've developed for labeling these clips
at scale
[Applause]
hi again
so even though we have lots of human
laborers the amount of training data
needed for training with networks
significantly outnumbers them so we try
to invest in a massive auto labeling
pipeline here's an example of how we
label a single clip a clip is a entity
that has dense sensor data like videos
imu data gps odometry etc
this can be 45 second to a minute long
these can be uploaded by our own
engineering cars or from customer cars
we collect these clips and then send
them to
our servers where we run a lot of neural
networks offline to produce intermediate
results like segmentation masks depth
point matching etc this then goes
through a lot of robotics and a
algorithm to produce a final set of
labels that can be used to train the
networks
one of the first tasks we want to label
is the road surface typically we can use
splines or meshes to represent the road
surface but those are
because of the topology restrictions are
not differentiable and not amenable to
producing this so what we do instead is
in the style of neural radiance fields
work from last year which is quite
popular so we use an implicit
representation to represent the road
surface
here we are querying xy points on the
ground and asking for the network to
predict the height of the ground surface
along with various semantics such as
curves lane boundaries road surface
rival space etc
so given a single xy we get a z together
these make a 3d point and they can be
reprojected into all the camera views
so we make millions of such queries and
get lots of points these points are
reprojected into all the camera views
in we are showing on the top right here
one such camera image with all these
points reprojected
now we can compare this point
reprojected point with the image space
prediction of the segmentations
and jointly optimizing this or all the
camera views was across space and time
produced an excellent reconstruction
here's an example of how that looks like
so here this is an optimized road
surface that reproduction to the eight
cameras that the car has and across all
of time and you can see how it's
consistent across both space and time
so a single car driving through some
location can sweep out some patch around
the trajectory using this technique
but we don't have to stop there
so here we collect collected different
clips
from the same location from different
cars maybe
and each of them sweeps out some part of
the road
cool thing is we can bring them all
together into a single giant
optimization so here these 16 different
trips are organized using
aligned using various features such as
roadages lane lines all of them should
agree with each other and also agree
with all of their image space
observations
together this is this produces an
effective way to label the road surface
not just where the car drove but also in
other locations that it hasn't driven it
again the point of this is not to just
build hd maps or anything like that it's
only to label the clips through these
intersections so we don't have to
maintain them forever as long as the
labels are consistent with the videos
that they were collected at
optionally then humans can come on top
of this and clean up any noise or
additional metadata to make it even
richer
we don't have to stop at just the road
surface we can also arbitrarily
reconstruct 3d static obstacles um here
this is a reconstructed 3d point cloud
from our cameras
the main innovation here is the density
of the point cloud typically these
points require texture
to form associations from one frame to
the next frame but here we are able to
produce these points even on textual
surfaces like the road surface or walls
and this is really useful to annotate
arbitrary obstacles that
we can see on the scene in the world
one more cool advantage of doing all of
this on server on the servers offline is
that we have the benefit of hindsight
this is a super useful hack because uh
say in the car then the network needs to
produce the velocity it just has to use
the historical information and guess
what the velocity is
but here
we can look at both the history but also
the future and basically cheat and get
the correct answer uh of the kinematics
like velocity acceleration etc
one more advantage is that we can have
different tracks but we can switch them
together that even through occlusions
because we know the future we have
future tracks we can match them and then
associate them so here you can see the
pedestrians on the other side of the
road are persisted even through multiple
occlusions by these cars
this is really important for the planner
because the planner needs to know if
it's if it saw someone it still needs to
account for them even then they are
occluded so this is a massive advantage
combining everything together we can
produce these amazing data sets that
annotate all of the road texture
or the static objects and all of the
moving objects even through occlusions
producing excellent kinematic
labels
all you can see how the cards turn
smoothly produce really smooth labels or
the pedestrians are consistently tracked
the park cars uh
obviously zero velocity so we can also
know that they are parked
so this is huge for us
this is one more example of the same
thing
you can see how everything is consistent
we want to produce a million such uh
labeled
clips and train our video
multicam video networks with such large
data set and really crush this problem
we want to get the same view that's
consistent that we're seeing here in the
car
we started our first exploration of this
with the remove the data project uh we
removed it in a very top a short time
span i think within three months
in the early days of the network we
noticed for example in low security
conditions the network can suffer
understandably because obviously this
truck just dumped a bunch of snow on us
and it's really hard to see but we
should still remember that this car was
in front of us
but our networks early on did not do
this because of the lack of data in such
conditions
so what we did we added the fleet to
produce lots of similar clips
and the fleet responded it did
so it produces um
is it play
yeah it produces lots of video clips
where shit's falling out of all other
vehicles
and we send this through our auto living
pipeline that was able to label 10k
clips in within a week this would have
taken several months with humans
labeling every single clip here
so we did this for 200 of different
conditions and we were able to very
quickly create large data sets and
that's how we were able to remove this
so once we train the networks with this
data
you can see that it's totally working
and keeps the memory that the subject
was there
and provides this
so finally we wanted to actually get a
cyber truck into a data set
for the remote radar
can you all guess where we got this clip
from i'll give you a moment
someone said it yes yes it's rendered
it's our simulation
it was hard for me to tell initially and
i if i may if i may say so myself it
looks pretty it looks very pretty um
so yeah in addition to auto labeling we
also invest heavily in using simulation
for labeling our
data
so this is the same scene as
seen before
but from a different camera angle
so a few things that i wanted to point
out for example the ground surface it's
not a plane asphalt there are lots of
cars and cracks and tower seams
there's some patchwork done on top of it
vehicles move realistically the truck is
articulated uh even goes over the curb
and makes a wide turn um the other cars
behave smartly they avoid collisions go
around cars uh and also smooth and
actual great smooth uh brake and
accelerate smoothly
the car here with the logo on the top is
autopilot actually auto part is driving
that car and it's making unproductive
left hand
and since it's a simulation it starts
from the vector space so it has perfect
labels
here we show a few of the labels that we
produce
these are vehicle cuboids with
kinematics
depth
surface normals segmentation but
andre can name a new task that he wants
next week and we can very quickly
produce this because we already have a
vector space and we can write the code
to produce these labels very very
quickly
so when does simulation help
it helps number one when the data is
difficult to source as large as our
fleet is it can still be hard to get
some crazy scenes like this couple and
their dog running on the highway while
there are other high-speed cars around
this is a pretty rare scene i'd say but
still can happen
and autopilot still needs to handle it
when it happens
when data is difficult to label um there
are hundreds of pedestrians crossing the
road this could be a mountain downtown
people crossing the road it's going to
take several hours for humans to label
this clip and even for automatic
labeling algorithms this is really hard
to get the association right and it can
produce like bad velocities but in
simulation this is trivial because you
already have the objects you just have
to spit out the cuboids and the
velocities
and also finally when we introduce
closed loop behavior where the cars
needs to be in a determining situation
or the data depends on the actions this
is pretty much the only way to get it
reliably
all this is great
what's needed to make this happen
number one accurate sensor simulation
again the point of the simulation is not
to just produce pretty pictures
it needs to produce what the camera in
the car would see and other sensors
would see so here we are stepping
through different exposure settings of
the real camera on the left side and the
simulation on the right side
we're able to pretty much match what the
real cameras do
in order to do this we had to model a
lot of the properties of the camera in
our sensor simulation um starting from
sensor noise motion blur optical
distortions even headlight transmissions
uh
even like diffraction patterns of the
windshield etcetera
we don't use this just for the autopilot
software we also use it to make hardware
decisions such as lens design camera
design sensor placement even headlight
transmission properties
second we need to render the visuals uh
in a realistic manner you cannot have
what in the game industry called jaggies
these are aliasing artifacts that are
dead giveaway that this is simulation we
don't want them so we go through a lot
of paints to produce a nice special
temple a special temporal anti-aliasing
we also are working on neural rendering
techniques to make this even more
realistic
yeah in addition we also use ray tracing
to produce realistic lighting and global
illumination okay that's the last of the
cop cars i think
we obviously cannot have uh really just
four or five cars because the network
will easily overfit because it knows the
sizes um so we need to have realistic
assets like the moose on the road here
um
we have thousands of assets in our
library and they can wear different
shirts and actually can move
realistically so this is really cool
we also have a lot of different
locations mapped and created uh to
create these uh sim environments
we have actually 2000 miles of uh
road built and this is almost the length
of the roadway from the east coast the
west coast of the united states which i
think is pretty cool
in addition we have built efficient
tooling to build several miles more on a
single day on a for a single artist
but this is just tip of the iceberg
actually most of the data that we use to
train is created procedurally using
algorithms as opposed to artists making
these simulation scenarios
so these are all procedurally created
roads with lots of parameters such as
curvature
various varying trees cones poles cars
with different velocities and the
interaction produce an endless stream of
data for the network
but a lot of this data can be boring
because the network might already get it
correct so what we do is we use also ml
based techniques to basically put up the
network to see where it's failing at and
create more data around the failure
points of the network so this is in
closed loop trying to make the network
performance be better
we don't want to stop there so actually
we want to create recreate any failures
that happens to the autopilot in
simulation so that we can hold autopilot
to the same bar from then on
so here on the left side you are seeing
a real clip that was collected from a
car
it then goes through our auto labeling
pipeline to produce a 3d reconstruction
of the scene along with all the moving
objects
with this combined with the original
visual information we recreate the same
scene synthetically and create a
simulation scenario entirely out of it
so and then when we replay autopilot on
it autopilot can do entirely new things
and we can form new worlds new outcomes
from the original failure this is
amazing because we really don't want
autopilot to fail and when it fails we
want to capture it and keep it to that
bar
not just that we can actually take the
same approach that we said earlier and
take it one step further
we can use neural rendering techniques
to make it look even more realistic
so we take the original original video
clip
we create a synthetic uh simulation from
it
and then apply neural rendering
techniques on top of it and it produces
this which looks amazing in my opinion
because this one is very realistic and
looks almost like it was captured by the
actual cameras
they saw results from last night because
it was cool and we wanted to present it
but yeah
yeah i'm very excited for what sim can
achieve
but this is not all [ __ ] because
network's trained in the car already
used simulation data we used 300 million
images with almost half a billion labels
and we want to crush down all the tasks
that are going to come up for uh the
next several months
with that i invite milan to see uh to
explain how we scale these operations
and really build a label factory
and spit out millions of labels
[Applause]
all right thanks ashok
hey everyone i'm milan i'm responsible
for the integration of our neural
networks in the car and for most of our
neural network training and evaluation
infrastructure
and so tonight i'd just like to start by
giving you some perspective into the
amount of compute that's needed to power
this type of data generation factory and
so in the specific context of the push
we went through as a team here a few
months ago to get rid of the dependency
on the radar sensor for the pilot we
generated over 10 billion labels across
two and a half million clips
and so to do that we had to
scale
our huge offline neural networks and our
simulation engine across thousands of
gpus and just a little bit shy of 20 000
cpu cars on top of that we also included
over 2000 actual autopilot full
self-driving computers in the loop with
our simulation engine
and that's our smallest compute cluster
so i'd like to give you some
idea of what it takes to take our neural
networks and
move them in the car
and so the
the two main constraints that we're
working on there here
are mostly latency and frame rate
which are very important for safety but
also to get proper estimates of
acceleration and velocity of our
surroundings
and so the meat of the problem really is
around uh the ai compiler that we write
and extend here within the group that
essentially maps the compute operations
for my apart torch model
to a set of dedicated and accelerated uh
pieces of hardware and we do that while
figuring out a schedule that's optimized
for throat put
while working on their severe sram
constraints
and so by the way we're not doing that
just on one engine but on across two
engines on the autopilot computer and
the way we use those engines here at
tesla is such that at any given time
only one of them will actually output
control commands to the vehicle while
the other one is used as an extension of
compute
but those roles are interchangeable both
at the hardware and software level
so how do we interact quickly together
as a group through these ai development
cycles well first we have been scaling
our
capacity to evaluate our software neural
network dramatically over the past few
years and today we're running over a
million evaluations per week on any code
change
that the team is producing and those
evaluations runs on over three thousand
actual footstar driving computers that
are hooked up together in a dedicated uh
cluster
and so on top of this we've been
developing really cool uh debugging
tools and so here is a video of one of
our tools which is uh helping developers
uh iterate through the development of
neural networks and comparing live the
outputs from different revisions of a
same neural network model as reiterating
life through a video clips
and so last but not least uh we've been
scaling our neural network training
compute dramatically over the past few
years and today we're barely shy of 10
000 gpus which just to give you some
sense in terms of number of gpu is more
than the top five publicly known
supercomputers in the world
but that's not enough and so i'd like to
invite ganesh to talk about the next
steps
[Applause]
thank you milan
my name is ganesh
and i lead project dojo
it's an honor to present this project on
behalf of the multidisciplinary tesla
team that is working on this project
as you saw from milan
there's an insatiable demand for speed
as well as capacity for neural network
training and elon prefetched this and a
few years back he asked us to design a
super fast training computer and that's
how we started project dojo
our goal is to achieve best ai training
performance and support all these larger
more complex models that andres team is
dreaming of and be power efficient and
cost effective at the same time
so we thought about how to build this
and we came up with
a distributed compute architecture
after all all the training computers out
there are distributed computers in one
form or the other they have compute
elements in the box out here connected
with some kind of network in this case
it's a two-dimensional network but it
could be any different network cpu gpu
accelerators all of them have compute
little memory
and network but one thing which is
common trend amongst this is it's easy
to scale
the compute
it's very difficult to scale up
bandwidth and extremely difficult to
reduce latencies and you'll see how our
design point catered to that how our
philosophy
addressed these aspects of traditional
limits
for dojo we envisioned a large compute
plane
filled with very robust compute elements
backed with large pool of memory and
interconnected with very high bandwidth
and low latency fabric and in a 2d mesh
format and on to this for extreme scale
big neural networks will be partitioned
and mapped to extract different
parallelism model graph data parallelism
and then in neural compiler
of ours will
exploit spatial and
temporal locality such that it can
reduce communication footprint to local
zones and reduce global communication
and if we do that
our bandwidth utilization can keep
scaling with the plane of compute that
we desire out here
we wanted to attack this all the way
top to the bottom of the stack
and remove any bottlenecks at any of
these levels
and let's start this journey in an
inside out fashion starting with the
chip
as i described
chips have compute elements our smallest
entity or scale is called a training
node
and the choice of this node is
very important to ensure seamless
scaling
if you go too small it will run fast but
the overheads of synchronization
will end software will dominate if you
pick it too big
it will have complexities in
implementation in the real hardware and
ultimately run into memory bottleneck
issues
because we wanted to address
we wanted to address latency and
bandwidth as our primary optimization
point let's see how we went about doing
this
what we did was we picked the farthest
distance a signal could traverse in a
very clock very high clock cycle in this
case two gigahertz plus and we drew a
box around it this is the
smallest latency that a signal can
traverse one cycle at a very high
frequency and then we filled up the box
with wires to the brink
this is the highest bandwidth you can
feed the box with and then we added
machine learning compute underneath and
then a large pool of sram
and last but not the least a
programmable
core to control
and this gave us our high performance
training node
what this is is a 64-bit superscalar cpu
optimized around matrix multiply units
and vector cmd
it supports floating point 32 b float 16
and a new format cfp8 configurable fp8
and it is backed by
one and a quarter megabyte of fast ecc
protected sram and the low latency high
bandwidth fabric that we designed
this might be our smallest entity of
scale but it packs a big punch
more than one teraflop of compute in our
smallest entity of scale
so let's look at the architecture of
this
the computer architects out here may
recognize this this is a pretty capable
architecture as soon as you see this
it is a super scalar in order cpu
with four wide vector and two wide vect
two wide uh four wide scaler and two
wide vector pipes we call it in order
although the vector and the scalar pipes
can go out of order but for the purest
out there we still call it in order and
it also has four-way multi-threading
this increases utilization because we
could do compute and data transfers
simultaneously and our custom isa which
is the instruction set architecture is
fully optimized for machine learning
workloads it has features like transpose
gather
link traversals broadcast just to name a
few
and even in the physical realm we made
it extremely modular such that we could
start averting these training nodes in
any direction and start forming the
compute plane that we envisioned
when we click together
354 of these training nodes we get our
compute array it's capable of delivering
teraflops of machine learning compute
and of course the high bandwidth fabric
that interconnects these
and around this compute array we
surrounded it with
high speed low power services 576
of them to to enable us to have extreme
i o bandwidth coming out of this chip
just to give you a comparison point this
is more than two times the bandwidth
coming out of the state-of-the-art
networking switch chips which are out
there today and network switch chips are
supposed to be the gold standards for i
o bandwidth
if we put all of it together
we get
training optimized chip
our d1 chip
this chip is manufactured in seven
nanometer technology it packs 50 billion
transistors in a miserly 645 millimeter
square
one thing you'll notice 100 of the area
out here is going towards machine
learning training and bandwidth there is
no dark silicon there is no legacy
support this is a pure machine learning
machine
and
this
is the d1 chip in a flip chip bga
package
this was entirely designed
by tesla team internally all the way
from the architecture
to
gds out and
package this chip
is like a
gpu level compute with a cpu level
flexibility and twice the network chip
level i o bandwidth
if i were to plot
the i o bandwidth on the vertical scale
versus teraflops of compute that is
available in the state-of-the-art
machine learning chips are there
including some of the startups you can
easily see why our design point excels
beyond power
now that we had this fundamental
physical building block
how to design the system around it
let's see
since d1
chips can seamlessly connect without any
glue to each other we just started
putting them together
we just put
500 000
training nodes together to form our
compute plane
this is 1500 d1 chips seamlessly
connected to each other
and then
we add
dojo interface process
processors on each end
this is the host bridge to typical hosts
in the data centers
it's connected with pci gen4 on one side
with a high bandwidth fabric to our
compute plane
the interface processors provide not
only the host bridge but high bandwidth
dram shared memory for the compute plane
in addition
the interface processors
can also allow us to have a higher radix
network connection
in order to achieve this compute plane
we had to come up with a new way of
integrating these chips together
and this is what we call as a training
tile
this is the unit of scale for our system
this is a groundbreaking integration of
25 known good d1 dies onto a
fan out wafer process tightly integrated
such that it preserves the bandwidth
between them the maximum bandwidth is
preserved there and in addition
we generated
a
connector a high bandwidth high density
connector that preserves the bandwidth
coming out of this training tile
and this style gives us nine beta flaps
of compute
with a massive i o bandwidth coming out
of it
this
perhaps is the biggest organic mcm in
the chip industry multi-chip module
it was not easy to design this there
were no tools that existed all the tools
were croaking even our compute cluster
couldn't handle it we had to our
engineers came up with different ways of
solving this they created new methods to
make this a reality
now that we had our compute plane
tile
with high bandwidth ios
we had to feed it with power
and here we came up with a new way of
feeding power vertically
we created a custom
voltage regulator module
that could be reflowed directly directly
onto this fan out wafer so what did we
did out here is we got chip
package and we brought pcb level
technology of reflow on fan art wafer
technology this is
a lot of integration already out here
but we didn't stop here
we integrated
the entire electrical thermal and
mechanical pieces out here
to form
our training tile fully integrated
interfacing with a 52 volt dc input
it's unprecedented this is an amazing
piece of engineering
our compute plane is completely
orthogonal
to power supply
and cooling
that makes
high bandwidth compute planes
possible
what it is
is a nine petaflop
training tile this becomes our unit of
scale for our system
and this
is real
i can't believe i'm holding nine
petaflops out here
and in fact
last week we got our first
functional training tile
and on a limited limited cooling
benchtop setup
we got some networks running
and i was told andre doesn't believe
that we could run networks
till we could run one of his creations
this is min gpt2 running on dojo
do you believe it
next up
how to form a compute cluster out of it
by now you must have realized our
modularity story is pretty strong
we just put together some tiles we just
styled together tiles
a two by three
tile in a tray makes our training matrix
and two trays in a cabinet
give 100 petaflops
of compute
did we stop here no
we just
integrated seamlessly we broke the
cabinet walls we integrated these styles
seamlessly all the way through
preserving the bandwidth there is no
bandwidth divert out here there is no
bandwidth clips all the tiles are
seamlessly connected with the same
bandwidth
and with this
we have an exopod
this is
one extra flop of compute
in 10 cabinets
it's more than a million training nodes
that you saw we paid meticulous
attention to that training node and
there are one million nodes out here
with uniform bandwidth
not just the hardware
the software aspects are so important
to ensure scaling
and not every job requires a huge
cluster so we plan for it
right from the get go
our compute plane
can be subdivided can be partitioned
into
units called dojo processing unit
a dpu
consists of one or more
d1 chips
it also has our interface processor and
one or more hosts
and this can be scaled up or down as per
the needs of any algorithm any network
running on it
what does the user have to do they have
to change their scripts minimally
and this
is because
of our strong compiler suite
it takes care of fine-grained
parallelism and mapping the pro problems
of mapping the neural networks very
efficiently onto our compute plane
our compiler is
uses multiple techniques to extract
parallelism
it can transform the networks to achieve
not only fine-grained parallelism using
data model
graph parallelism techniques
it also
can do optimizations to reduce memory
footprints
one thing because of our
high bandwidth nature of the fabric is
enabled out here is model parallelism
could not have been extended to the same
level as what we can
it was limited to chip boundaries now we
can because of our high bandwidth we can
extend it to training tiles and beyond
thus
large networks can be efficiently mapped
here at low batch sizes and extract
utilization and new levels of
performance
in addition our compiler is capable of
handling high level dynamic control
flows like loops if then else etc
and our compiler engine is just part of
our entire software suite
the stack consists of
a extension to pytarch that ensures the
same user-level interfaces that ml
scientists are used to
and our compiler generates code on the
fly
such that it could be reused for
subsequent execution it has a llvm
backend that generates the binary for
the hardware
and this ensures we can create optimized
code
for the hardware without relying on even
single line of handwritten kernel
our driver stack
takes care of the multi-host
multi-partitioning that you saw
a few slides back
and then we also have
profilers
and debuggers in our software stack
so with all this
we integrated
in a vertical fashion we broke the
traditional barriers to scaling
and that's how
we got modularity up and down the stack
to add to new levels of performance
to sum it all
this is what it will be it will be a
fastest ai training computer
for x the performance at the same cost
1.3 x
better performance per watt that is
energy saving and 5x smaller footprint
this will be dojo computer
we are not done we are
assembling our first cabinets pretty
soon
and we have a whole next generation plan
already we are thinking about
10x more with different aspects that we
can do all the way from silicon
to the system again we will have this
journey again we're recruiting heavily
for all of these
areas thank you very much
and next up
elon will update us on what's beyond our
vehicle feet fleet for ai
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
oh
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
now unlike unlike dojo obviously that
was not real
uh
so doj is real uh the tesla bot will be
real
um but
basically if you think about what we're
doing right now with the cars tesla is
arguably the world's biggest robotics
company because our cars are
like
semi-sentient robots on wheels
and with
the
full self-driving computer essentially
the the inference engine on the car
which will keep evolving obviously and
uh dojo
and all the
neural nets recognizing the world
understanding how to navigate through
the world
uh it it kind of makes sense to put that
onto a humanoid form
they're also quite good at sensors and
batteries and
actuators
so
we think we'll probably have
a prototype sometime next year that
basically looks like this
and it's intended to
be friendly of course
and uh navigate through a world uh built
for humans
and
uh eliminate dangerous repetitive and
boring tasks
um we're setting it such that it is um
at a mechanical level at a physical
level you can run away from it
and and most likely overpower it
so
hopefully that doesn't ever happen but
um you never know
so it's uh it'll be a you know
a light
a light
yeah five miles an hour you can get run
faster than that'd be fine
[Laughter]
um so
yes it's a
round
uh 5.8
um
has sort of a screen where the head is
for useful information um but as
otherwise basically got the autopilot
system in it so it's got cameras got
eight cameras and
full-size driving computer
and making use of all of the same tools
that we use in the car
so
um i mean things i think that are really
hard about uh
having a useful humanoid robot is cannot
navigate through the world without being
explicitly trained
i mean without explicit like uh
line-by-line instructions
um
can you can you talk to it and say you
know please uh pick up that bolt
and uh attach it to
the car with that wrench
and it should be able to do that
um
it should be able to you know please you
know please go to the store and get me
the following groceries
um that kind of thing
so
yeah i think we can do that
um
and
yeah
this i think will be quite quite
profound because if you say like what is
the economy it is uh
at the foundation it is labor so
what happens when there is uh
you know
no shortage of labor
um that's why i think long-term that
there will need to be universal basic
income
yeah
but but not right now because this robot
doesn't work so
we just didn't need a minute
so
um
yeah but i think essentially in the
future physical work will be a choice if
you want to do it you can but you won't
need to do it
and
yeah i think it obviously has profound
implications for the economy because
given that the economy at its
foundational level is labor i mean
capital is capital equipment it's just
distilled labor
then
is there any actual limit to the economy
maybe not
so
yeah
join our team and help build this
all right so i think we'll we'll have
everyone come back on the stage and you
guys can ask questions if you'd like
yeah
[Applause]
you
[Music]
all right there we go
[Music]
all right cool you guys brought me back
on
i just like stage
try to get
the camera angle from there
but not from the side
all right cool
so we'll probably turn the lights back
on
and uh
yeah great um
so we're having to answer any questions
you have about anything on the software
hardware side where things are going
and yeah fire away
um we have because the lights are like
interrogation lights so we actually
cannot see ah there we go great
all right cool
i can just okay there we go first off i
mean thanks to all the presenters that
was just super cool to see everything
i'm just curious at a high level and
this is kind of a question for really
anyone who wants to take it um to what
extent are you interested in publishing
or open sourcing anything that you do
for the future
um well i mean it is fundamentally
extremely expensive to create uh the
system so
uh
somehow that has to be paid for i'm not
sure how to pay for it if it's fully
open sourced
um
yeah unless people want to work for free
but but i should say that uh this is
if other car companies want to license
it and use it in their cars that would
be cool this is not intended to be just
limited to tesla cars
is for the dojo supercomputer so did you
solve the compiler problem of scaling to
these many nodes or is or
if it is solved is it only applicable to
dojo
because
i'm doing research in
deep learning accelerators and getting
the correct scalability
or the distribution even in one ship is
extremely difficult from the
research projects perspective so i was
just curious
excuse me mike for bill
you
have we solved the problem not yet are
we confident we will solve the problem
yes
we have demonstrated networks on
prototype hardware now we have models
performance models showing the scaling
the difficulty is as you said how do we
keep the localities
if we can do enough model parallel
enough data parallel to keep most of the
things local we just keep scaling we
have to fit the parameters in our
working set in our sram that we have
and we flow through the pipe
there's plenty of opportunities
sorry as we get further scale for
further processor nodes have more local
memory
memory trade also bandwidth we can do
more things but as we see it now
the applications that tesla has we see a
clear path
and our our modularity story means we
can have different ratios different
aspects created out of it i mean this is
something that we chose for our
applications
internally
sure
the locality portion of it given that
training is such a soft scaling
application
uh even though you have all this compute
and have a high bandwidth
high bandwidth interconnect
it it could not
give you that performance because you
are doing computations on limited memory
at different locations so i was that's
very curious to me when you said it
solved because i i just jumped onto the
opportunity and would love to know more
given that how much you can open source
yeah
yeah i guess the proof's in the pudding
um
so we should have dojo operational next
year um and
um i think we'll we'll obviously use it
for
uh training video training it's i mean
fundamentally this is about like um
the the
primary application initially is we've
got vast amounts of video and how we
train vast amounts of video uh
as efficiently as possible
and
uh also shorten the amount of time like
if you're trying to train train to a
task um
like just in general innovation is um
how many iterations and what is the
average progress between each iteration
and so if
if you can reduce the time between
iterations uh the rate of improvement is
is much better
so
um you know if it takes like sometimes a
couple days for a model to train versus
a couple hours that's a big deal
but the the asset test here and um you
know what i've
told the dojo team is like it's
it's successful if the
uh
software team wants to turn off the gpu
cluster
but if they want to keep the gpp cluster
on
it's not successful
so yeah
hi
right over here
i love the presentation thank you for
getting us out here loved everything
especially the simulation part of the
presentation i was wondering uh it
looked very very
very uh realistic are there any plans to
maybe expand simulation to other parts
of the company in any way
hi i'm ian glow uh i manage the
autopilot simulation team
so as we go down the path to
full self driving we're gonna have to
simulate more and more of the vehicle
currently we're simulating vehicle
dynamics but we're going to need bms
we're going to need the mcu we're going
to need every single part of the vehicle
integrated and that actually makes the
autopilot simulator really useful for
places outside of autopilot so i want to
expand or we want to expand eventually
to being a universal simulation platform
but i think before that we're going to
be spinning up a lot of optimist support
and then a little bit further down the
line that we have some rough ideas on
potentially how to get uh
the simulation infrastructure and some
of the cool things we've built into the
hands of people outside of the company
optimus is the code name for the tesla
bot
oops
optimus uprine
[Laughter]
hi
this is ali jahanian
thank you for the great presentation and
putting all of these cool things
together
yeah for a while i have been thinking
that uh the car is already a robot so
why not a humanity robot
and i'm so happy that today
you mentioned that you are going to
build such thing
especially i think that this can uh give
opportunity for rays of uh putting multi
modality together for instance we know
that in
the example that you are showed that
there was a dog and
with some passengers or running together
the
language
and symbolic processing can really help
for
visualizing that
so i was wondering
if i could hear a little more about
this type of putting modalities together
including language and vision because i
have been working with for instance mini
gpt's and andre put out there
and
yeah i had i didn't hear much about
other modalities that's going into the
car or at least in the simulation
is is there any comment
that
you could tell us
well driving is fundamentally uh
basically
almost entirely vision neural nets uh
like we're basically it's running on a
biological vision
neural net and what we're doing here is
a silicon camera neural net um
so
and there are there's there is some
amount of uh audio uh you know you want
to hear uh if um there's like emergency
vehicles or
uh
you know uh
i guess converse with the
people in the car
um
you know if somebody's yelling something
at the at the car that car needs to
understand what that is
um
so
you know all things that are necessary
for it to
be fully autonomous
yeah
thank you
hi uh thank you for all the great work
that you've shown uh my question is for
the team uh because the data that was
shown was seems to be predominantly from
the united states that the the fsd
computer is being trained on but as it
is being as it gets rolled out to
different countries which have their own
road systems and
challenges that come with it how do you
think that it's going to scale like like
i'm assuming like the ground up is not a
very viable solution so how does it
transfer to different countries
uh well there is we actually do train on
using data from
probably like 50 different countries
um but we have to pick
you know in as we're trying to advance
full self driving we need to pick one
country and since we're located here we
pick the us um
and then we get a lot of questions like
why not even canada like well because
the roads are a little different in
canada different enough um
and so when trying to solve a hard
problem uh you want to
uh say like okay what's the
let's not add additional complexity
right now uh let's just solve it for the
us and then we'll extrapolate to the
rest of the world but we do use video
from all around the world yeah i think a
lot of a lot of what we are building is
very country agnostic fundamentally all
the computer vision components and so on
don't care too much about country
specific uh
sort of features every you know
different countries have roads and they
have curbs and they have cars and
everything we're building is fairly
general for that
yeah and there's the the prime directive
is don't crash right and that's true for
every country yes this is the prime
directive
um
and um
even right now the car is pretty good at
not crashing um
and so
just basically um
whatever it is don't hit it even if it's
a ufo that crash landed uh on the
highway and still don't hit it
you should not need to recognize it in
order to not hit it
so that's very important
and i want to ask that
when you do the photometric process
multiview geometry how much of an error
do you see is it like one millimeter one
centimeter so i'm just if it's not
confidential
sorry question what is the what's it
what's the difference between the
synthetic
sure
what is the difference between the
synthetically created geometry to the
actual geometry
yeah it's usually within a couple
centimeters three or four centimeters
that's the standard deviation
merge with different kind of modalities
to bring down that error
we primarily try to find scalable ways
to label um in some occasions we use
other sensors to
help benchmark but we primarily use
cameras for this system
okay thanks yeah i i mean i think we
want to aim for the car to be positioned
uh accurately to the the sort of
centimeter level um
you know
something on that order obviously it
will depend on distance like close by
things can be much more accurate than
farther away things because and they
would matter less because the car
doesn't have to make decisions much
farther away and as it comes close it
will become more and more accurate
exactly
a lot of questions
thanks everybody my question has to do
with sort of ai and manufacturing it's
been a while since we've heard about the
alien dreadnought concept
is the humanoid that's behind you guys
is that kind of brought out of the
production health timeline and saying
that humans are underrated in that
process
um well sometimes like some
you know something that i say is uh
taken to too much of an extreme
there
there are parts of the tesla system that
are almost completely automated and then
there are some parts that are almost
completely manual
and
if you were to walk through the whole
production system you would see a very
wide range from yeah like i said fully
automatic to
almost completely manual
but the vast majority it's most of it is
is already uh automated
um
so and then
with the
some of the design architecture changes
like going to
large
aluminum
high pressure die cast
components we can take the entire rear
third of the car and cast it as a single
piece and now we're going to do that
the front third of the car is a single
piece
so the the body line
um
drops by like 60 to 70 percent in size
um
but yeah the the robot is not is not
prompted by
specifically by manufacturing
needs it's it's just that
we're just obviously making the pieces
that
are needed for a useful humanoid robot
so i guess we probably should make it
and if we don't someone else would well
and so i guess we should make it
and make sure it's safe
i should say like also manufacturing
volume manufacturing is extremely
difficult um and underrated and we've
gotten pretty good at that
it's also important for that humanoid
robot like how do you make the human
robot not be super expensive
and
hi
uh thank you for the present
presentation
and my question will be about skilling
of dojo
and uh in particular how do you scale
the compute nodes in terms of
thermal
thermals and power delivery because
there is only so much heat that you can
dispense
and only so much power that you can
bring to
like cluster rack
and how do you want to scale it and how
do you point to scale it in multiple
data centers
sure
hi
i'm bill i
one of the dojo engineers the um
so from a thermal standpoint and power
standpoint
we've designed it very modular so what
you saw on the compute tile that will
that will cool the entire tile so we we
once we hook it up to it is liquid
cooled on both the top and the bottom
side um it doesn't need anything else
and so when we talk about clicking these
together
once we click it to power and we once we
click it to um
cooling it will be fully powered and
fully cooled
and all of that is
less than a cubic foot
yeah
so tesla has a lot of expertise in power
electronics and in uh in cooling so we
took uh the power electronics expertise
from the vehicle powertrain
and the sort of the advanced cooling
that we developed
for the power electronics and for the
vehicle and applied that to the super
computer
because as you point out uh getting heat
out is
extremely important just really heat
limited
so
um
yeah so it's funny that like
at the compute level it's operating at
less than a volt
which is a
very low voltage there's a lot of amps
so therefore a lot of heat
i squared r is what really bites you on
the ass
um hi uh my question's also similarly a
question of scaling
um so it seems like a natural
consequence of using you know
significantly faster training hardware
is that you'd be either training models
over a lot more data
or you'd be training a lot more complex
models which would be
potentially significantly more expensive
to run at inference time on the cars
uh i guess i was wondering like if there
was a plan to like also
um
apply dojo as something that you'd be uh
using like on the self-driving cars and
if so like
you know do you foresee additional
challenges there
i can
so as you could see like android's
models are not just for cars like there
are auto labeling models there are other
models that are
like beyond car application but they
feed into the car stack so so dojo will
be used for all of those too
not just the car
inference part of the training
yeah i mean the dojo's
first application will be consuming
video data for training for that would
then be run in the inverse inference
engine on the car
but uh
and that i think is an important uh test
to see if it actually is good or but is
it actually better than gpu cluster or
not um so
but then beyond that it's basically a
general a generalized neural net
training computer
but it's very much optimized to be a
neural net so
you know cpus and gpus uh
they're they're they're not made to be
um
they're not they're not designed
specifically for training neural nets um
we've been able to make gpus especially
very efficient for
portraying neural nets but that's not
that was never their design intent so
it's it's bc gpus are still essentially
running it uh neural net training in
emulation mode so
um with with dojo we're saying like okay
let's just let's just asic the whole
thing
let's just
have this thing that's it's built for
one purpose and that is neural net
training
and just generally any system that is
designed for a specific
purpose will be better than one that is
designed for a general purpose
hey i had a question here
hi um
so you described two separate systems
one was for vision therefore planner and
control um does dojo love you train
networks that cross that boundary and
second thing is if you were able to
train such networks would you have the
onboard compute capability in the fst
system to be able to run that in in
under your tight latency constraints
thanks
yeah i think we should be able to train
uh planner networks on dojo or any gpus
it's really invariant to the platform um
and i think uh if anything once we make
this entire thing end to end it'll be
more efficient than decoding a lot of
these intermediate states so you should
be able to run faster if you make the
entire thing uh into in your neural
networks we can avoid a lot of decoding
of the intermediate states and only
decode essential things required for
driving the car
yep certainly and to endness and as the
guiding principle behind a lot of the
network developments and over time in
the stack neural networks have taken on
more and more functionality and so
we want everything to be trained
end-to-end because we see that that
works best but we are building it
incrementally so right now the interface
there is vector space and we are
consuming it in the planner but nothing
really fundamentally prevents you from
actually taking features and eventually
fine-tuning end-to-end uh so i think
that's definitely where this is headed
yeah and the discovery really is like
what are the right architectures that we
need to place in network blocks to make
it amenable to the task so like on a
describe we can place spatial rnns to
help with the uh perception problem uh
and now it's just neutral network so
similarly for planning we need to bake
in search and optimization into the
planning into the network architecture
and once we do that you should be able
to do planning very quickly uh similar
to c plus plus algorithms
okay
okay
i think i had a question very similar to
what he was asking about
it seems like a lot of neural nets
around computer vision
and kind of traditional planning you had
model predictive control in solving
convex optimization problems very
quickly
and
i'd wonder if there's a compute
architecture that's more suited for
convex optimization or the model
predictive control uh solutions very
quickly
yeah 100 if you want to bake in like i
said earlier if you want to bake in
these architectures that do say model
protein control but just like replace
some of the blocks with neural networks
or if we know the physics of it we can
also use physics-based models part of
the neural network's forward pass itself
so we are going to go towards a hybrid
system where
we will have neural network blocks
placed together with a physics-based
blocks and more networks later so it'll
be a hybrid stack and what we know to do
well we place with explicitly and what
the networks are created we'll use the
networks to optimize this uh so better
end-to-end stack with this architecture
baked in
i i mean i do think that
so as long as you've got like um
surround video
uh
neural nets for understanding what's
going on and can uh
convert
those surround video into vector space
then you basically have a video game
um and if
you know if you
it's like if you're in grand theft auto
whatever you can you can make the cars
drive around and pedestrians walk around
without crashing so
um you can do you don't have to have a
neural net for control and planning um
but it's probably
ultimately better um
so
but i think you can probably get to
in fact i'm sure you can get to much
safer than human with control and
planning
primarily in c plus plus with
perception vision in
neural nets
hi
my question is we've seen other
companies for example use reinforcement
learning and machine learning to
optimize
power consumption and data centers and
all kinds of other internal processes my
question is are is tesla using machine
learning within its manufacturing design
or other engineering processes
i
i discourage use of machine learning
because it's really difficult
unless you basically unless you
have to use machine learning don't do it
it's usually a red flag when somebody
says we want to use machine learning to
solve this test i'm like that sounds
like [ __ ] um
so
uh
99.9 percent of time you do not need it
um
so
yeah
but so it's kind of like a
you you reach for machine learning when
you when you
need to not but it's i've not found it
to be a convenient easy thing to do
um it's a super hard thing to do
that may change if you've got a humanoid
robot that can
you know understand
normal instructions
um
but
yeah
generally minimize use of machine
learning in the
factory
hi um based on your videos from the
simulator uh it looked like a
combination of graphical and neural
approaches i'm curious what the set of
underlying techniques uh that are used
for your simulator and specifically for
neural rendering if you can share
yeah so we're doing uh
at the bottom of the stack it's just
traditional game techniques
uh just rasterization real time
uh you know very similar to what you'd
seen like gta
on top of that we're doing real-time ray
tracing and then those results were
really hot off the press um i mean we
had that little asterisk at the bottom
that that was from last night
we're going into the neural rendering
space we're trying out a bunch of
different things
we want to get to the point where the
neural rendering is the
the cherry on the top that pushes it to
the point where the models will never be
able to overfit on our simulator
currently we're doing things similar to
photorealism enhancement
there's a paper a recent paper photo
enhancing photo realism enhancement
but we can do a lot more than what they
could do in that paper because we have
way more labeled data way more compute
and also much we have a lot more control
over environments
and we also have a lot of people who can
help us make this run at real time
um but we're going to try whatever we
can do to get to the point where we can
train everything just with the simulator
uh if we had to but we will never have
to because we have so much real world
data that no one else has
it's just to fill in the little gaps in
the real world
yeah i mean
the simulator
is very helpful when there's like these
rare cases like like um
you know like
collision avoidance right before an
accident
um and then
ironically that the better our cars
become at avoiding accidents the fewer
accidents there are so then our training
set is small so then we have to make
them crash in the simulation
so it's like okay minimize potential
injury to
uh pedestrians and people in the car
you have five meters you're traveling at
you know 20 meters per second um
take what actions would minimize
probability of injury
we can run that in some
cars driving down the wrong side of the
highway that kind of thing
happens occasionally but not that often
um for your humanoid contacts i'm
wondering if you've decided on what use
cases you're gonna start with and what
the grand challenges
um
are in that context to make this viable
well i think for the humanoid for the
tesla bot um
optimus
it's basically going to start with
just dealing with
work that is
boring repetitive and dangerous
basically what is the work that people
would least like to do
um
hi um so quick question about
your simulations um obviously they're
not perfect right now so are you using
any sort of domain adaptation techniques
to basically bridge the gap between your
simulated data and your actual
real-world data because i imagine it's
kind of dangerous to
just deploy models which are solely
trained on simulated data so maybe some
sort of explicit domain adaptation or
something is that going on anywhere in
your pipeline
so currently uh i mean we're producing
the videos straight out of the simulator
uh the the full clips of kinematics and
everything and then we're just
immediately training on them but it's
not the entire data set it's just a
small targeted segment and we only are
evaluating based on real world video um
we're paying a lot of attention to make
sure we don't ever fit uh and if we have
to start doing fancier things we will
but currently it's we're not having an
issue with it overfitting on the
simulator we will as we scale up the
data um and that's what we're hoping to
use neural rendering to bridge that gap
to push that even further out um we've
already done things where we're using
like the same networks in the car but
retrain it to detect sim versus rail to
drive our art decisions
um and that's actually helped um prevent
some of these things as well
yeah just to emphasize that
overwhelmingly the data set is the real
video from the cars on the actual roads
uh nothing's weirder or uh or has more
corner cases than reality
um it's gets really strange out there
but but then if if we find say a few
examples of something very odd
and there's some very some for some very
odd pictures we've seen
then in order to train it effectively we
want to
create simulations
uh say a thousand simulations that are
that are variants of that
quirky thing that we saw
the foot to fill in the some important
gaps and and make the system better and
really all of this is about over time
just
reducing the probability of of a crash
or an injury and
it's called the march of nines like how
do you get to 99.999999
uh safe you know and
it yeah
each nine is an order of magnitude
difficulty increase
uh thanks so much for the presentation i
was curious about
the tesla bot um
specifically i'm wondering
if there are any specific applications
that you think the humanoid form factor
lends itself to
and then secondary
um
because of its human form factor is
emotion or companionship at all thought
about
on the product roadmap at all
um
well we certainly hope this does not
feature in a dystopian
sci-fi movie
but uh you know like
really at this point
we're saying like maybe this robot can
just we're trying we're trying to be as
literal as possible can it do um boring
dangerous repetitive
jobs that people don't want to do
and
uh
you know once you can have it do that
then maybe you can do other things too
but
that's the that's the thing that we
really great to have
so
it could be your buddy too i mean buy
one and have it be or your friend and
whatever
i'm sure that people think of some very
creative uses
so
uh so
um so firstly thanks for the the really
incredible presentation um my question
is on the ai side um so one thing we've
been seeing is that with some of these
language modeling ais we've seen that
scaling has just had incredible impacts
in their capabilities and what they're
able to do
so i was wondering whether you're seeing
similar kinds of effects of scaling in
in your
neural networks in your applications
absolutely a bigger network typically we
see it performs better provided you have
the data to also train it with and this
is also what we see for ourselves
definitely in the car we have some
latency consideration to be mindful of
and so there we have to get creative to
actually deploy much much larger
networks but as we mentioned we don't
only train neural networks for what goes
in the car we have these um
auto labeling pipelines that can utilize
models of arbitrary size so in fact
we've traded a number of models that are
not deployable that are significantly
larger and work much better because we
want 100 like we want much higher
accuracy for the auto labeling and so
we've done a lot of that and there we
definitely see this trend
yeah the order labeling is uh
an extremely important important part of
this whole whole situation
without the order labeling i think we
would not be able to solve the
self-driving problem it's kind of a
funny form of distillation where you're
using these very massive models plus the
structure of the problem to do this
reconstruction and then you distill that
into neural networks that you deploy to
the car but we basically have a lot of
neural networks and a lot of tasks that
are never intended to go into the car
yeah and also as time goes on that you
get new frames of information so you
really want to make sure your computer
is distributed across all the
information as opposed to just taking a
single frame and hogging on it for say
200 milliseconds you actually have newer
frames coming in so you want to like use
all of the information and not just use
that one frame
i think
one of the things we're seeing is that
the car's predictive ability is um is
quite is eerily good
um
it's really getting better than human in
terms of predicting like you say like
what
predict what this road will look like
out when it's out of sight like it's
around the bend and it predicts the road
with very high accuracy
and
you know
predict pedestrians or cyclists wherever
behind you know where to just see a
little corner of the bicycle and
a little bit through through the windows
of the bus and its ability to predict
things is going to be much better than
humans like really way way beyond right
yeah we see this often where we have
something that is not visible but the
neural network is making up stuff that
actually is very sensible sometimes it's
eerily good and you have to like you're
wondering this is in the training set
and actually
actually in the limit you can imagine
the neural net has enough parameters to
potentially remember earth so
in the limit it could actually give you
the correct answer and it's kind of like
an hd map back baked into the weights of
the neural net
i have a question about the design of
the tesla bot specifically in order uh
how important is it to maintain that
humanoid form
to build hands with five fingers
uh that also respects the weight limits
could be quite challenging you might
have to use cable driven and then that
also causes all kinds of issues
um i mean this is just going to be
bought version one and we'll see
so
the
it's
it needs to be able to do things that
that people do um and uh
you know be a generalized you know
humanoid robot
um
i mean you could make you potentially
have it give it like you know
two fingers and a thumb or something
like that
um
you know for now we'll we'll give it
five fingers and and see
see if that works out okay
it probably will it doesn't need to be
like uh you know have like
incredible grip strength
but it needs to be able to work with
tools
so and you know carry a bag that kind of
thing
all right thanks a lot for the
presentation
so an old professor of mine told me that
um the thing he disliked a lot about his
tesla was that the autopilot ux didn't
really inspire much confidence in the
system especially when like objects are
spinning classifications are flickering
i was wondering like even if you have a
good self-driving system how are you
working on convincing tesla owners other
road users or other road users and just
the general public that your system is
safe and reliable
well i think that's that's
the cars
a while back cars used to spend they
don't they don't spin anymore not in the
if you've seen the fsd
beta videos they
they're they're pretty solid um
and they will be getting more solid yeah
as him add more and more data and train
these multi-camera networks like these
are pretty decent actually just like few
months old and it's really improving
it's not a done product uh and that
we've never minds we can clearly see how
this is just going to be like perfect
but perfect for space because why not uh
all the information is that in the
videos it should produce a given lots of
data and good architectures
um
and this is just an intermediate point
in the timeline
i mean it's clearly headed to way better
than human without question
my turn oh
hi here um i was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about the short to
medium-term economics of the bot i guess
i understand the long-term vision of
replacing physical labor
but i also think repetitive dangerous
and boring tasks tend to not be
so highly compensated and so i just
don't see how to reproduce uh
you know start with a supercar and then
break into like the lower end of the
market how do you do that for a robot
humanoid
well i guess you'll just have to see
hello hi
um i was curious to know how the car ai
prioritizes
occupant safety versus pedestrian safety
and what thought process goes into like
deciding how to make this into the ai
well i mean we
the the thing to appreciate
is that from the computer standpoint
everything is moving slowly
so uh think you know to a human uh
things are moving fast to the computer
they are not moving fast so i think this
is in reality somewhat of a false
dichotomy not that it will never happen
but it will be very rare
um
you know if you think it was like
you know going the other direction
like rendering
you know with full ray tracing uh
neural net enhanced graphics on
something like cyberpunk or in any you
know advanced video game
you know doing 60 frames a second
uh
perfectly rendered
like how long would it take a person to
even render one frame
and without any mistakes
can be done i mean it would take like a
month
just to
just render one one frame out of 60 in a
second in a video game
it's uh
computers are fast and humans are slow
i mean for example
uh on on the rocket side the you you
cannot steer the rocket to orbit
um we actually hooked up a joystick to
see if anyone could steal the rocket
orbit but
you need uh
to react at
roughly
six seven hertz uh people can't do it
not even now that's pretty low you know
we're talking more like
even for like
30 hertz type of thing
hi um with the over here uh with
hardware 3 there's been lots of
speculation that with larger nets it's
hitting the limits of what it can
provide
how much headroom has the extended
compute modes provided at what point
would hardware 4 be required if at all
well i'm confident that hardware 3 or
the full stop driving computer 1 will be
able to
achieve full self driving at a safety
level much greater than a human probably
i don't know
at least two or three hundred percent
better than a human um then obviously
there will be a future hardware for or
full self-driving computer too
which we'll probably introduce with the
cybertruck um so maybe in about a year
or so
uh
that is
probably well that'll be about four
times more capable roughly
um
but it's really just going to be
like can we take it from say for
argument's sake 300 safer than a person
to a thousand percent safer
um
you know just like there are people on
the road who with with varying driving
abilities but we still let people drive
it you don't have to be the world's best
driver to be on the road
so as we see
so
yeah
guess what's new
all
um
right
are you worried at all since you don't
have any depth sensors on the car that
people might try like adversarial
attacks like
printed out photos or something to try
to trick the rgb
neural network
yeah like what pull some like wiley cody
stuff
you know like paint the tunnel on the on
the wall
it's like oops
um
we haven't really seen much of that um
i mean
for sure like like right now if you
pr most likely if you had like a
a t-shirt with a
t-shirt with like a stop sign on it
which i actually have a t-shirt with a
stop sign on it and and then you like
flash the car
it will it will stop
i i proved that
um but
we can obviously as we see these uh
adversarial attacks then we can we train
uh the cars to uh
you know notice that well it's actually
a person wearing a t-shirt the stop sign
on it so it's probably not a real stop
sign
hi uh my question is about um the
prediction and the planning i'm curious
how do you incorporate uncertainty into
your uh you know planning algorithms
do you just basically assume you know
you mentioned that you run the um
the autopilot for all the other cars on
the road do you assume that they're all
going to follow those rules or are you
accounting for the possibility that well
they might be bad drivers for example
yeah we do account for multi-modal
futures it's not that we just choose one
we account for this person can actually
do many things and
we use that actual
physics and kinematics to make sure that
they're not doing a thing that would
interfere with us before we act um so if
there's any uncertainty we are
conservative and then would yield to
them of course there's a limit to this
because if you're too conservative then
it's probably not practical so at some
point we have to assert
and we even then we make sure that the
other person can
yield to us and
act sensibly
i should say like
um
like before we introduce something into
the fleet we will run it in shadow mode
and so and we'll see what what would
this neural net for example have done in
this particular situation
um
because and then effectively the drivers
uh are training it training the net so
if the neural net would have
uh controlled and you know and say
veered right but the person actually
went left it's like oh there's a
difference why was there that difference
yeah and secondly
all the human drivers are essentially
training the neural net uh as to what is
the correct course of action
assuming it doesn't then end up in a
crash you know doesn't count in that
case
yeah and secondly we have various
estimates of uncertainty like flickr
and when we observe this we actually uh
say we are not able to see something we
actually slow down the car to be again
safe and get more information before
acting uh yeah we don't want to be
brazen and just go into something that
we don't know about we only go into
places where we know about
yeah but um yeah
it should be like
aspirationally that the car should be
the less it knows the sl you know the
slower it goes yeah
which is not true at some point but now
yeah yeah we've yeah
should we
speed proportionate to confidence
thanks for the presentation so i am
curious
appreciate the fact that the fsd is
improving but if you have the ability to
improve one component along the ai stack
to present it today whether it is
simulation data collections planning
control et cetera which one in your
opinion is going to have the biggest
impact for the performance of the full
self driving
system
it's really the area under the curve of
this like multiple points and if you
improve anything uh it should improve
the area
i mean in the short term it's arguably
we need all of the nets to be um
surround video uh and so we still have
some legacy this is a very short term
obviously we're fixing it fast but
there's
there's still some nets that are not
using surround video
um and i think ideally that all use
surround video
yeah very yeah i think a lot of puzzle
pieces are there for success we just
need more strong people to also just
help us
make it work yeah that is the actual box
so that is the actual bottleneck i would
say i'm really one of the reasons that
we are putting on this event exactly
what well said andre that um
there's just a tremendous amount of work
to do to make
make it work so that's why we need um
talented people to join in and
solve the problem
uh thank you for the great presentation
lots of my questions answered
but one thing is
uh when
imagine that now you have
a large amount of data even unnecessary
how do you consider that like there's a
forgetting problem in neural networks
like how are you considering those
aspects and also
another one are you considering online
learning or continuous learning
so
that maybe
each driver can have their version of
uh self-driving
software
i think i think i know the literature
that you're referring to that's not some
of the problems that we've seen and we
haven't done too much continuous
learning we train the system once we
find in a few times
that sort of goes into the car we need
something stable that we can evaluate
extensively and then we think that
that's good and that goes into cars so
we don't do too much learning on spot or
continuous learning and don't face the
forgetting problem uh but there will be
settings that you can say like if you do
do you want are you typically a
conservative driver or do you want to
drive fast or slow you know it's like
i'm late for my i'm late for the airport
uh could you go faster than you know
basically the kind of instructions you'd
give to your uber driver
it's like i'm late for the flight please
hurry um or take it easy or you know
whatever your style is
so let's take a few more questions here
so and then we'll call it a day all
right so as our models have become more
and more capable and i guess you're
deploying these models into the real
world um one thing i guess that's
possible is for ai to become more i
guess misaligned with what humans desire
so i guess is that something that you
guys are worried about as you guys
deploy more and more robots um or do you
guys like we'll solve that problem when
we get there
yeah i think that we should be worried
about ai um you know like
what we're trying to do here is i say
narrow ai uh
pretty narrow like just make the car
drive better than a human um
and then have the humanoid robot be able
to do basic stuff um
uh
you know so
um at the point at which you sort of
start get uh superhuman intelligence uh
yeah i don't know all bets are off
um
but
you know and that's that's that's you
know
that'll that'll probably happen but but
what we're trying to do here at tesla is
make useful
ai that
people love and and is
unequivocally good that's our
you know try to aim for that
okay maybe one more question
hi uh my question is about the camera
sensor in the beginning of the talk you
had mentioned about building a synthetic
animal
and if you think about it
a camera is a very poor approximation of
a human eye and a human eye does a lot
more than take a sequence of frames
have you looked into like there are like
these days are like cameras like event
cameras have you looked into them or are
you looking into a more flexible camera
design or building your own camera for
example
well with hardware four we will we will
have a next generation camera uh but i
have to say that the the current cameras
we have not reached the limit of the
current cameras uh so
um
and i'm confident we can achieve full
self-driving with much higher safety
than
humans with the current cameras and
current compute hardware
um
but
you know
are we good to be a thousand percent
better rather than 300 better
so
we'll see continued evolution on on our
levels
and pursue that goal and i think in the
future
people will look back and say
wow i can't believe we had to drive
these cars ourselves
you know it'll like self-driving cars
will just be just a normal like
self-driving elevators
you know uh elevators used to have
elevator operators
and uh there's someone there with like
you know big big relay switch
operating the elevator
and then every now and then they'd get
tired or you know some make a mistake
and share somebody in half so
um so now we uh you know we made
elevators automatic and you just go and
you press the button and you can be in a
100 story skyscraper and
don't really worry about it just go and
press a button and
the elevator takes you where you want to
go
but it used to be that all elevators
were operated manually manually it'll be
the same thing like for cars
all cars will be automatic
and then um and electric obviously um
so there will still be some gasoline
cars and some manual cars just like
there are still some horses
so
um all right well thanks everyone for
coming and i hope you enjoyed a
presentation and thank you for the great
questions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you